Maksim Chmerkovskiy slam former Dancing  with the Stars partner Hope Solo no love  lost here  former Dancing with the Stars Pro was as  unfiltered as ever on the podcast  allegedly not holding back any feelings  about a season 13 partner he said quote  she's just a person you can have a life  growing up but if you're a bad person  there's no excuse for that  the feud stems from allegations hope  made in her 2012 memoir in which she  claims Maxim quote manhandled her and  quote slapped her across the face during  rehearsals Maxim has denied the  allegations et has reached out to hopes  rep for comment  max parted ways with a hit ABC show  after winning season 18